pues si está nuevamente con nosotros el
economista ni en la calle àngel gracias
nuevamente por retomar esta conexión con
nosotros en este programa especial pues
esta noticia que está pues teniendo
repercusiones y reacciones a nivel
mundial estamos precisamente con nuestro
periodista especializado en economía
jorge hurtado jorge todo y la palabra
pues para preguntar todo lo que
concierne a la economía y que hagamos en
él un tema importantísimo el suministro
de gas de rusia a ucrania jorge así que
bueno daniele bienvenido de ser uno de
los principales temores de hecho de este
conflicto cuál sería la incidencia a
corto y a largo plazo
de este conflicto en europa del este
respecto al suministro de gas
respecto al suministro de gas tenemos la
experiencia del año 2014 que nos muestra
que no se acaba el suministro de gas de
rusia hacia europa gazprom esta misma
mañana ha dicho que el flujo de gas
sigue siendo constante y que no se ha
hecho ningún cambio pero no podemos
olvidar el enorme riesgo que supone
porque es verdad que para muchos países
sobre todo los países del norte de
europa
la dependencia del gas ruso es altísima
estamos hablando de países que dependen
en más de un 60 70 en algunos casos del
cien por cien de llegar ruso en su
suministro de gas no es fácil no es
fácil sustituir ese gas primero porque
es gas
relativamente barato desde luego pero
además porque
sustituirlo con gas licuado sea
noruega o de eeuu es además de muchísimo
más caro mucho más complicado en cuanto
a la cantidad de gas que se puede
suministrar por lo tanto la
incertidumbre es máxima pero también
tenemos que recordar al menos desde un
punto de vista de tranquilidad que en
conflictos anteriores es a ese
suministro no se ha interrumpido le
pregunto daniela ahora cuáles serían los
países mayormente afectados en europa
con una posible interrupción de este
suministro y ya europa y occidente
estaban buscando nuevos proveedores
estos nuevos proveedores es viable que
en algún momento se sea interrumpir de
forma total el suministro con rusia
abastezca en la necesidad de toda europa
es posible
sustituir el gas ruso por gas natural
licuado que luego se regasifica en las
terminales que hay por toda europa
españa por ejemplo tiene aproximadamente
el 30 por ciento de la capacidad de
regasificación de europa y puede apoyar
en ese sentido pero es carísimo es muy
caro eso es lo que no nos estamos dando
cuenta no yo creo que y además quiénes
serían los países que podrían
suministrar eeuu y noruega poco más
qatar a lo mejor pero fundamentalmente
esos 2
en cuanto al impacto el impacto es
enorme para los países del norte de
europa pero también es importante para
los países del sur muchas veces cuando
hablamos de las exportaciones de rusia y
de la dependencia de el comercio con
rusia nos olvidamos que además del
petróleo y del gas que son muy
importantes el paladio el aluminio y el
trigo son también exportaciones rusas
hacia europa que son claves para la
industria y para la alimentación
bien hace un momento hablábamos del
aumento que uno de los mercados que más
reaccionó fue el petróleo y el petróleo
ahora mismo se ha pasado la barrera de
los 100 dólares cuál va a ser la
incidencia en la inflación en los
próximos días hay algunos economistas
que apuntan a que próximamente superará
inclusive los 110 dólares cuál es el
efecto inmediato de este aumento
drástico dramático diríamos del del
petróleo
la subida del petróleo y del gas
tendría si se mantuviese a estos perdón
la subida del petróleo y el gas si se
mantuviese a estos niveles durante todo
el año
podría suponer un aumento del 15 por
ciento de la inflación de la unión
europea que ya es muy alta es decir
estaríamos hablando de un nivel de
inflación cercano al 6 y medio o incluso
7 por ciento a nivel medio de la unión
europea con todos estos factores
incluidos verdad
si ya la inflación en los últimos meses
ha tenido una tendencia alcista hemos
visto los bancos centrales del mundo de
eeuu y de europa e inclusive en américa
latina a aumentar o endurecer sus
políticas monetarias y eso será de una
forma más agresiva con este conflicto en
europa del este
mucho más agresiva mucho más agresiva
porque además lo más probable es que
ante la
subida de la inflación y ante el entorno
en el que estamos lo que nos encontremos
es que el banco central europeo no suba
las tasas de interés no suba los tipos y
mantenga las recompras por lo tanto la
presión inflacionaria vía
monetaria se añade es decir el claro uno
de los factores clave para reducir la
presión inflacionaria de estos en estos
meses que estábamos comentando era que
el banco central europeo iba a subir
tipos
a reducir las recompras de activos si el
banco central ante la crisis de ucrania
decide no llevar a cabo esa
normalización de la política monetaria y
además los precios del petróleo y del
gas se disparan por tensiones
geopolíticas el efecto de
depresión inflacionaria es muy muy
importante
hablemos de la incidencia en el precio
de los alimentos a nivel mundial sabemos
que ahora mismo lo los contenedores de
trigo los que pasan o que transportan
maíz inclusive están tratando de sortear
los buques militares rusos
podría haber una suspensión de estas
rutas por el conflicto y cuál sería la
incidencia en los precios o en la
inflación misma
bueno de nuevo otro factor de presión
inflacionista
extremadamente importante y además que
hace mucho daño porque porque ya antes
del conflicto de ucrania los precios el
índice de precios de alimentos que
publica la fao ya mostraba que el link
el precio de los alimentos estaba
máximos históricos- esto es clave porque
porque además si ahora se produce una
disrupción en las cadenas de suministro
se empiezan a romper algunos de los
de los pasos clave para traer muchos de
estos productos
claramente va a haber una un efecto
cadena en los precios de los que
tienen que compartir
o este conflicto en américa latina
porque a lo mejor muchos pueden decir
pues eso queda muy lejos de nosotros
pero realmente la economía pues ha
demostrado que todo afecta y pues es un
mercado global como afectaría esto a los
mercados de américa latina y cuál sería
digamos el más afectado por todo lo que
está ocurriendo en ucrania danielle
bueno claramente para la américa latina
y un factor relativamente positivo que
es que va a exportar más materias primas
no soja por supuesto cobre por supuesto
petróleo también ese es un factor
relativamente positivo cuál es el
problema el problema es quien no
compensa a los factores negativos que
son los que acabamos de hablar la subida
de los precios de los insumos
industriales y la subida de los
alimentos por lo tanto para
latinoamérica lo que ya era una
recuperación lenta y con una alta
inflación se convierte en un riesgo
adicional de que la inflación sea mayor
y por lo tanto la recuperación peor es
verdad que lo que probablemente ocurra
es que algunos de los países que tienen
debilidad en sus monedas porque no
tienen reservas suficientes de dólares
pues a lo mejor se alivia un poco con un
poco de exportación mayor de materias
primas pero no es suficiente cuando la
gran mayoría de los países de
latinoamérica y particularmente
argentina-brasil en méxico tienen
importantes desequilibrios tanto
fiscales como comerciales pues daría el
gracias por su tiempo por su análisis
por estar con nosotros en esta
transmisión especial de france 24 un
gran abrazo desde la ciudad de bogotá y
bueno seguramente vamos a estar
enlazando con usted en la medida de lo
posible àngel muchísimas gracias
nosotros continuamos desarrollando lo
que ha sido toda esta sección económica
de este conflicto jorge y vamos a hablar
entonces de los indicadores las bolsas
por supuesto todas por el piso la
mayoría cerraron en negativo la bolsa de
shanghai perdió 1,7 por ciento y la de
chen se en un 2,2 por ciento mientras
las acciones chinas cerraron a la baja
siguiendo el movimiento de las ventas de
las acciones mundiales después de que
rusia invadiera ucrania con ataques en
las principales ciudades en europa los
futuros europeos perdieron un 3.5 por
ciento la bolsa la bolsa de parís abrió
con fuertes pérdidas tras el ataque
militar de rusia contra ucrania y el
cac-40 llegó a caer hasta un 4,26 por
ciento en los primeros minutos de la
sesión la bolsa española se desplomó un
4,31 por ciento tras conocer la noticia
del ataque ruso contra ucrania pues
sobre gracias entonces como siempre por
toda la información económica